the hand up of the top that sort of
looks like almost like a maestro we
wanted to see the machinations of the
shadow puppetry like usually they would
either
it either be more invisible when they do
it or they would get rid of it in post
but we really wanted to
to show that these stories are yes based
on things that have happened but also a
creation
of people as they tell it as it morphs
and changes through history so
that like moment of the hand there is
this just to even further show like
you know this is um we kind of are all
all puppets you know in a way
hi i'm nia de costa and i'm the director
of candyman and this
is my scene breakdown
[Music]
so this is our shadow puppet sequence
that goes through
a couple of the different men and a boy
who've been candyman and the first one
is sherman
who we see a lot of in the film and this
is all practical
cut out paper shadow puppetry done by an
amazing company in chicago called manual
cinema
this scene in particular is taking place
in cabrini green
we also see this moment in the film
itself and portrayed
in with actual actors this is just
another way of looking at it
and it kind of points to why we wanted
to do shadow puppetry in the first place
because we wanted to
we want it to be the medium of the
storytelling of the passing on of the
lore so
even within some of this like the
details aren't exactly the same as what
was in
in the film just to show that like the
teller of the story is just as important
as the story itself in between each sort
of representation
you see anthony painting because it's
we're kind of showing like he's
in a way kind of seeing these men and
being influenced by them
this is one of my favorite shots in the
um shadow puppeteer sequence with
everyone
outside the window staring in
i think it's so eerie the way the eyes
are cut out and um it was really fun
coming up with the way
people would look in in the shadow
puppetry with manual cinema
their super creative brought so much
brilliant inspiring imagery to the table
and then we kind of honed it together
and came down to you know a specific
look for
for all of these i think that image for
me like is so
potent because it is what the movie's
about it's like the violence from the
mob
i think that imagery was so clear and
everything about it just really
encapsulates like the sort of hatred and
the violence that is inherent
in that sort of mob mentality so i think
that might be my favorite sort of shot
from this
but overall i think my favorite like
vignette is um is the kids because it's
the most heartbreaking to me
[Music]
so
[Music]
this we did a lot of editing with a lot
of back and forth with manual cinema
like how best to
to tell the story and a lot of people
picked up on that he was inspired by
george cindy jr who was the youngest
person at 14 to be executed by the state
and a detail from his true story but
that we did not want to use here was
that he was so small that he had to sit
on a bible
in the electric chair and so i mean
that's a big reason why we went with
shadow puppetry is like we didn't want
to
put people through this like with actual
people and
and besides it connecting to like you
know storytelling and how how old it is
and this being an old form of
storytelling we wanted to um
um also kind of have a filter between
the horror of what's happening and the
[Music]
audience
[Music]
so what you're seeing is him painting
meeting this woman
and they fall in love um there was
actually
there was actually a sort of sequence
where they're like not like making out
but like he's like on top of her and
it's supposed to be very romantic and i
was like i cannot have puppets
even alluding to having sex so i will
not be including that
in this um and i also want to be very
specific and like you know make sure we
stay
on on topic this is our version of
depicting the the robotic story
it's also spoken in the film which for
me was really important to have a black
man telling the story of daniel
robitaille as opposed to the first film
where it's a sort of uncaring white
academic
[Music]
at the end of this we have anthony sort
of himself
in a way becoming possessed by the
stories by this this history
by the weight of it
shadow puppets were very very very
beginning of the process um
there's always gonna be shadow pups in
the film the way we use them
um we developed throughout the shooting
um
and we added even more after after we
finished shooting because we were like
this
this is great and we can we can do more
with it so yeah it was sort of like we
always knew we'd use it and then how we
used it and how much we used it
um developed as we were shooting and in
post
cara walker was obviously a huge
influence not necessarily in deciding to
do shadow puppets but in envisioning how
it could be very eerie and connected to
history
and specifically black history another
artist whose work was
influential was lottie reiniger's work
she did
a lot of silhouette animation equally as
eerie and disturbing so
so that was great i think in just
showing like we can do this in a way
that's really evocative
but when it came to the actual like
what's in the film manual cinema really
came up with their own
language and we you know we created
something specific to our story
the hand up of the top that sort of
looks like almost like a maestro we
wanted to see the machinations of the
shadow puppetry like usually they would
either
it'd either be more invisible when they
do it or they would get rid of it in
post but we
really wanted to to show that these
stories are yes based on things that
have happened but also a creation
of people as they tell it as it morphs
and changes through history so
that like moment of the hand there is
this just to even further show like
you know this is um we kind of are all
all puppets you know in a way
you know we really shift the point of
view in uh in
in our film from the first one and when
we really pull apart like the mythology
of candyman we kind of look into like
what makes a myth and who gets to decide
what the myths are who gets to decide
who the villains are and and the martyrs
and the monsters and
and that was something that was really
compelling to me as we you know
constantly deal with black people
getting killed
um in horrifying ways in this country so
um i think that's something that we
really wanted to examine
um i think the first movie is really
preoccupied with
you know cabrini green and gang violence
and like graffiti and like things like
that where you're like very like present
things and then we wanted to kind of
talk about the cyclical nature of what
happened to danny robitaille as a person
um and how that affects the community
today um
so a couple weeks later
more razor blades and more candy
he'd been innocent so he's real candy
man ain't a he
candy man's the whole damn hive
thank you for watching the scene
breakdown please check out candyman and
get your tickets on fandango
you